right now nfts in total are probably
maybe tens of billions in market cap
true or false you think that it could be
a 10 trillion dollar industry by the end
of this decade if you're expanding it to
all the ancillary stuff no doubt like
i'll give you a quick scenario of
something that i know is going to happen
and you'll begin to see just how much
revenue this could end up driving let's
say my last company quest nutrition
let's say that we partnered up and so
health and fitness remains a big thing
for me and what i want to do then is i
go to quest and i say hey let's partner
on this thing i'm going to create an ar
experience where one of the characters
that somebody has bought one of my nfts
uh let's just make it snowbow to keep it
interesting snowbow shows up at the mall
and through your ar either your glasses
or your phone you see it and we could
put like a physical sign or something to
let people know to take out their phone
and look but you look and you see
snowboard and snowbow is you know waves
you on you go around the corner and
there is this gigantic mech from the
story you you know you're the only one
that sees it if you're holding the one
of the nfts in your wallet and that
thing reaches out and offers you a quest
protein bar now it's obviously not real
but you take that and you now have that
is in and of itself an nft that you now
have in your wallet and then a new line
appears on the floor and it walks you to
let's say a gnc where you can redeem
that for an actual
bar and so there's going to be all kinds
of partnerships promotions things like
that that will really begin to expand
this and then if you look into so my
brother-in-law is launching a chocolate
company called chocolate and the thing
about this that i think is incredibly
interesting is he's working out an nft
strategy that would allow the early
adopters the ability to determine what
flavors he creates so that he creates
this sort of enclave of people you know
relatively small group that buy this nft
in order to get into that sort of having
massive influence they become the taste
testers he knows he'll always be running
batches for that number of people and
they get to have like a really big
influence on the direction that he goes
and so as companies begin to integrate
this stuff and give more perks in places
that you wouldn't think like physical
like a food company that kind of thing
integrating nfts into that it really is
it is going to be limited only by
people's imagination because the
technology is
unbelievable and we're really just
scratching the surface